I've I'm doing something that I've
actually never done before me chess
which is I'm playing classical chess
this is a 20 minute plus 10 monthly
arena so it's much longer game than I'm
used to playing which will hopefully
give me more time to explain things
calculate more hopefully be more
instructive higher-quality chess so why
this currently playing my opening which
I can't complain too much about I
usually enjoy playing the London from
the white side and from the black side
got one of my favorite openings from
both colors these days there's a few
moves in this position like complain I
have three I can take I can play c3 um
it looks like this guy has never played
a classical game as well so sort of
unknown place um blitz seems like a very
beautiful player I'll play knight c6
here now the the typical London position
is what happens after c3 and actually c3
is not considered to be the best move
because black can hit white with Queen
b6 and this is what I'm looking forward
to I'm looking forward to just
equalizing right away and after Queen b6
my preparation goes on for a bit longer
so we'll see what happens
chess spera mental I like this idea real
chess yeah finally some real chess not
some garbage one-minute or hyperbolic or
variants so it's going to be relaxing
today Queen b6
and I think I mean this line has been
around for for ages and this Queen b6
move is one of the reasons why the
London used to not be so popular because
a lot of white players would just run
into this not know what to do or black
would just equalize and light would
usually be maybe scared away from
playing the London these days there's
ways to avoid this line for white for
example white could play c3 here and
after a knight c6 play Knight d2 and
then Queen b6 could be met with Queen b3
and there's some differences in the move
order where you don't want your knight
to develop to f3 so early because you
want to make sure your your Queen side
can can be better off if the b2 plant is
attacked he plays Queen c2 and now I'm
I'm actually gonna be in the dilemma
here because I had this position
a few days ago in a blitz game it was
against like a 1400 and I played what I
thought was a very good line I took on
the d4
my opponent took back with night I took
my opponent took and then I played
Bishop f5 luckily I looked over that
game I played a few days ago and it
turns out Bishop f5 was just a bad move
because it actually allows screen take a
five and after a Queen's 8b2 there is
some issues for black but I forget what
what were the issues
I know bish about five is risky in
certain situations where I could end up
winning the rock on a one but White's
Queen could come back maybe Queens III
or something or even Bishop d3 and then
if queen take a one there should be five
check I'm gonna avoid all of that I'm
just gonna play a natural move g6 now
I'm actually preparing Bishop a5 I'm
preparing the ship g7 and I'm trying to
keep the pressure of course I'm always
happy if white takes on c5 cuz then I
take back with Queen and then I have
future ideas at e5 also happy if white
plays Bishop d3 that runs into c4 so I
will admit I'm sort of out of my
preparation but I think this is going to
be a very reasonable position so he
plays Mike to you too
so now the question is do I play Bishop
a5 immediately or do I do something else
I play Bishop a5 immediately he plays
Queen B 3 C 4 we can trade on b6 that
looks fine
very often what happens in these sort of
like middlegame structures is the queen
will come to be three I play c4 we trade
on b6 I get the open a file and then I
got the Queen side the Queen side space
and the eventual idea will be to push my
pawn to to b4 and create some weakness
in White's position so what I'll do
because this is a much slower game than
what I'm used to I'll try and interact
with the chat more we do have a couple
commenters hello to check to the King
thanks for watching light just played h3
maybe preparing against my h5 giving the
bishop some breathing room
[Music]
I've had this sort of structure many
times before but not usually with the
pawn on d6 so I'm curious if h6 would be
a good move here to prepare g5 and then
play e6 because my bishop probably wants
to be on this diagonal to support a b4
break
and it's kind of hard for white to stop
g5 unless he wants to play h4 let's do
that it's all about finding harmony with
the pieces like if my bishop goes to g7
and I Castle it looks normal it looks
solid and safe but like the bishop
really has no purpose I'm on g7 he plays
g4 right away which now puts me in a
situation do I want to retreat to d7 or
do I want to play Bishop g4 both move
seemed very feasible if I play better
before I'm I am giving away the bishop
here but it might be worth it does it
before and I take e4 Knight a key for
this almighty to move we can trade more
if I play Bishop d7 he's probably gonna
get movie 4 and at some point Bishop d7
it's just easier for for white to play
e4
you're not entirely pleased with Hopkin
playing this so far there's already
decisions to to make so okay let's catch
it this would be for a take take
he could play 92 immediately we can
trade on d2 actually don't like that cuz
he gets in he's gonna get an e4 anyway
if I play Bishop d7 right away he can't
play e4 right away cuz I just take this
pawn and then in the meantime I just
want to play some kind of B v e6 and
White's gonna have to prepare and then
even if like gets in e4 maybe I can just
ignore it if I have the pawn on d5 so
I'll play Bishop d7 it looks weird
looks like I'm kind of wasting time
there's a game that this sort of reminds
me of between capablanca or table Baca
was black he was playing Janowski who is
White's and he made some decision like
early on the game's move the bishop from
f5 to d7 before playing east six and it
worked out really well for him so I'm
gonna play u6 here Bishop e5 should not
be a problem or is it
there should be five tick tick mmm no
let's play b5 first
b5 is more flexible I know I want to
play b5 I'm not entirely sure if I want
to play you 6 Jessie h f2 is in the chat
exercise sparks is in the chat very well
known IG in the London for whites not
allow the pawn to reach before it's true
exercise sparks it's going well I
usually don't stream this early but I
had in my schedule to stream at 11 a.m.
Central time I think I started the
stream at like 11:15 so trying to stay
on schedule
95 he wants the bishop hair which I
think that's ok and allow him to take
the bishop I think here I'll play you 6
if he takes I take with Knights you'll
also take right away but then he takes
with pawn what's going on they're taking
any 5 take 95 94 when you trade more
take that looks very reasonable actually
because my bishop will just plan itself
on c6
but the thing is I don't want to
simplify too quickly
maybe I'm just completely overthinking
this against a player who I should
probably beat regardless but I do want
to play accurately so e6 take take if my
mic comes to d7 it can go to b6 later
then my king can come to decide my
Bishop come in to d6 that just seems a
bit more harmonious with with the
structure he could come he could
temporarily get the bishop her but I
think this idea with the eventual King
g7 envision g6 should neutralize most
things give black a comfortable position
murmur one two three
like c6 I will have to go back and look
at the theory here cuz I don't know if
g6 was actually the best move maybe what
I should have done was not go for this
sort of structure with g6 maybe I should
have just played Bishop g7 in castle and
be patient
in hindsight yeah maybe that was a
better option but too late he plays
Knight f3 I'm very tempted just to play
b5 or before increase the pressure
I could throw in g5 but maybe not
necessary it's played before now the one
issue the one one of the main
differences compared to this position in
more typical London middle games from
the lack perspective is usually I have
my light square bishop along this
diagonal which would take away the b1
square from a rook in this case if the B
file opens the brook will be able to go
to be one in some cases so he takes
which looks like he just wants to play
remove the other Knight to e5 I'm gonna
take with Bishop I want to keep keep my
pawn in the B file because someday I
might take and then try and play b5
before yet again I'm expecting 95 here
very partial game so far Queens got
traded early if he plays 95 there will
probably be more trades 95 oh no 95 ok
so he castles now it's a question what
to do
there's one move that really sticks out
here is this move 94 just like get
initiative like a taxi 3 and see what
light does i'm also may be preparing
some Bishop d6 may be preparing f6 to
stop 95 that just looks like a good move
don't do that without too much
calculation like if you can improve a
piece with initiative it's usually the
type of move you can play quickly
without thinking too much
nosey Matt's surprised by a classical
games this is actually my first ever
classical game me chess so I better not
lose this of the provisional 1500
grading and I was contacted by someone I
think who helps run the elite chess 4545
League which is like the the popular
classical like online league and I would
have joined but I didn't have like an
established classical rating I meet 20
classical games so hopefully by the end
of this stream all I'll have at least a
few games and a more established rating
but it takes a long time to play
classical games like this game alone
could take could take over an hour with
increment some more comments in the chat
actually just got here yeah we could go
back to the opening I think I miss
played it though I'm gonna take on
before yeah that's actually the nice
thing about having the BB pawns in that
position is I play B for once but I can
have before another time he plays a3
kicking my bishop if I play Bishop d6 we
could trade and then he plays 95 hmm so
Bishop e7 looks fine
I don't think black wants to trade gear
and black has a little bit more space
policy for knight on e4 and I think the
goal is to play some restrictive chess
like maybe at some point play f6
restrict this Knights maybe play g5 kick
the bishop maybe go for h5 long-term
plan also long-term plan of playing like
B 5 B 4 so yeah this is actually
reminding me a lot of the structure in
this capablanca Janowski game where
capablanca had some structure somewhat
similar to this and he like completely
destroyed his opponent by playing on
both sides of the board and white just
can handle like all the all the play
from black a very instructive game rook
F t1 I don't see the purpose so maybe
he's preparing 92 I would think trades
slightly benefit White's so I will try
not to trade c3 could be an interesting
move undermine the pawns if he takes get
some mini fork
so I'm imagining he plays 92 and then I
get two moves in a row because I have
the move here play B 592 b4 probably not
great
Oh actually b5 mighty tune I take T to
rotate to u 2 and then before it's
interesting with the pin maybe even
winning upon let's say B 5 B 5
he plays 95 I can play Bishop e7 and
then we have 6 next yeah I'm gonna play
me 5 even though this is classical I
still have to manage my time sometimes
the problem with classical you think you
have a limited time when in reality it's
still a relatively quick game
so moves like b5 deserves to be played
more quickly than that some people are
saying 5 f6 which will probably come
eventually
he plays mighty 2 so this is well I
calculated like I take take before I'm
attacking the apon 3 times and that just
looks good
I mean he could play E 4 I don't think
it does anything
yeah let's do it the one issue is my
rook on h8 is still out of the game like
when the time is right I want to play
King d7 cuz right now if I take he takes
he's already preparing work da too so
like if it was my move in this position
I might I might go for King g7 and just
like keep all the pressure we'll see
what he does Bishop do you want I don't
think that changes anything does it
there should be one maybe he's preparing
a for the thing is if he ever plays a
four I played b3 and his eight pawns a
goner so I'll play King g7 just
connecting the rooks
and this way my reckoning eights
defended there's some potential to
double up in certain lines I do might
want to throw in g5 like very soon
because I don't want this rook to be
tied down to the h-bomb
okay it's hard to keep up with with all
these comments and focus like mostly on
the game dirt old cent elite chess
studying the chats which I can look at
really briefly wait what
Oh derp da just shared the game in the
chat okay fair enough I thought you was
sharing something else well thanks for
doing that
kingi - I don't see the point behind
that seems like a nothing move seems
like the King doesn't want to be on g2
either cuz there's some x-ray vision if
I throw in g5 like my Matt oh and thanks
for the comment derp was i sayin dirt
dog turd old whatever-your-name-is
thank you okay bishop g3 so the question
is do I want to take right away do I
want to double up there's probably some
different options for black if I take on
a3 he takes I take this rookie take take
that's good enough probably yeah I just
saw a fine
so the line I'm calculating is be take a
three
rook take a three rook to a3 bishop take
a three rook a - I can play like brocade
hello ex villager good to see you again
as well very slow pace today so if
anyone has like any questions I can
probably just answer questions like
during these games and not not flag like
other streams but so far it's it's been
very positional and this is what you'll
see a lot like against the London like
sometimes the best strategy for black is
to get some structure like this with the
double Queen side pawns or BB pawns and
then go for the pawn storm and I have
had a lot of games where big black or
sometimes from the white side you just
went upon with the von storm so Bishop
take a three
now this phone's gonna be very strong
this pond should probably be the the
main thing which wins black the game
because when the time is right there's
always opportunities to push it so I'll
play rook a8
and I might just want to trade rooks I
could probably simplify a lot with
Bishop t6 I had a game yesterday against
against a viewer against hero and I was
like up a pawn and some end game
crushing and I made the mistake of
simplifying too much into some obstacle
or Bishop ending and it didn't quite
work out for me so I have to be careful
like not to trade too many pawns and
just get a a simple position where I can
defend uh he plays out for which I don't
know if it has a threat my pawns
defendant on g5 Bishop c1 looks kind of
tempting but you might just take on a
than play King f2 oh wait no bishop c1o
Bishop c1 take on a 8ya
king f2 I take on that floor doesn't win
upon 4 for black okay it's still gonna
take some work here
now what to do meet some fan
Bishop c1 looks attractive but I don't
see the follow-up after taking King F to
c3 looks interesting but it might be too
ambitious because I want to leave the
pawn there until so I'm sure it pushing
works there's some idea like my this
Bishop is really bad right now wondering
if I can somehow maneuver it to e4
someday that would be the dream I think
I'll just start with f6 I get solidifies
the g5 fun but it also opens up some
potential maneuver in some times these
positions is just about being patient
not making any like rash decisions
just slowly improving until until
there's some opportunity Oh some people
wanted me to go back and look at the
opening I have 8 minutes left I can
quickly show the opening it was a London
with c3 which I started off the game
very confidently I played Queen b6 and
then he played Queen c2 which I realized
I need to do more preparation on most
people will play Queen b3
and then it's like a very standard and
enjoyable line for black after a c4
Queen c2 I started thinking because I
had this same line a few days ago
against a 1400 I completely butchered
the opening and actually got a lost
position around moved 10 against a 1400
as black because what happened was I
forgot the move order exactly but I took
he took I took he took with well maybe
he took with a pawn I played some Bishop
f5 move though I looked at stock fish
after and like it completely refuted
Bishop f5 because Queen take a five
take and this is going to be one of the
lines I'll have to go back and look at
because it does get really complicated
so I decided to play g6 but then I kind
of mixed up plans and I played Bishop f5
maybe too early and we got the structure
so anyway it's my move
he plays Bishop c2 I wonder if he knows
that I'm streaming if i refresh the page
just Shawn streaming reload oh it does
ok so he might be watching it's
something to keep in mind ok well now
this Bishop EA Bishop g6
maneuver is hard to accomplish meanwhile
my rooks hide down to the bishop bishop
c1 still not super effective I am up a
pawn I'm wondering now if I bring my
King to like say King c7 or King d6
don't work because he takes with the
discovered check thinking about bringing
my king to b4
okay I'm gonna trade we'll trade a lot
of things I'm pretty sure I can grind
them down we're never getting in some
obstacle our Bishop ending if we ever
trade off everything like the rooks and
the bishops then it should just be an
easy winning King pawn ending so am i
muted slight overdrive from time to time
is that okay or mute let me know is the
audio okay okay and let me know if it's
clipping too cuz there might be some
issue with my microphone Oh your
opponent is muting your stream to avoid
cheating little clicking I could turn
the volume slightly down but I could
just try and talk more or less loudly to
absolutely perfect well that's good to
hear okay well we're taking the rook
yeah I was noticing that too and it
hasn't happened before and I I kept all
the settings the same so I'm wondering
if there's something something I did
accidentally or how do i how do I fix it
turn the game down
okay I turn the game below 50% so maybe
that did something that might just force
everyone to turn their volume up but
okay so he's keeping all the bishops on
the board I think the goal for black is
to trade bishops and math pawns so I
want to keep all the pawns on the board
let's start with just the normal dish of
c6 oh and my computer's not it's about
to die this is a five hour tournament
I'm probably not gonna stream for five
hours
but I was planning to stream for at
least a couple hours you plays King f2
so Glock needs some plan White's plan is
probably just gonna be to wait around so
there's a few plans I could bring the
King to g7 and maneuver the bishop I
could try and bring the King to b5 play
Bishop before I could probably try one
plan if it doesn't work and then try the
other plan what to do how to win I was
not expecting this game to be so tough
it's only the first round
okay I'm bringing in the King to to e7
and then eventually g7
cuz then laughs I think I think if we
can trail off flights where bishops
then the dark squared Bishop ending
should be should be very close to
winning because why pawns are on light
squares these pawns are fixed on dark
squares I have some f5 break if I want
if he avoids the Bishop trade than my
Bishop can be on the nice diagonal so
yeah if some people are suggesting moves
in the chat I'm gonna try not to look at
the moves until the position happens
bird is saying a muted you okay I think
the audio should be okay
just make sure yeah it looks okay I was
like little barking which shows the
levels just resigned okay I think it's
time to stop looking at the chance
he plays Bishop a5 I don't know what
that does let's keep keep going along
with the plan Oh bird Oh Birds my
opponent I see it all makes sense now I
was like who's muting me okay so he's
not listening to me I'm sure he'll
listen to or watch the replay of this or
something
I will okay I should note that listening
to me stream oh by the way thank you ex
I sparks for subscribing really
appreciate it
what was I saying
if someone listens to me streaming while
they're playing me I don't consider it
cheating usually when I explain the
position explaining ideas I am making
the assumption that they're listening to
me and with that I will I will be
careful about certain things as I say
okay so White's just waiting like with
this plan even if he sees it or if he
knows that it's coming it's gonna come
anyway and in the position like this I I
think I can say anything and yeah it's
it's not gonna affect how the game
proceeds so I will be curious like will
he trade bishops will he keep you ships
on the board if he keeps bishops on the
board
I might just plant the bishop on e4 and
then walk my team all the way back and
play Bishop b4 this could be a very long
ending
and the like the idea with this position
is try to try and torture whites like we
want to create moments where white has
to like constantly defend the problem is
this could also be torture for black
because it's always blocked when used to
be thinking about like the next ideas
and sometimes it's easier for white to
just like wait and wait for whatever
idea black is trying but okay I finally
have allowed some decision he avoids a
trade let's play Bishop before if I
can't just play like Bishop III to b2
and push the pawn just control the the
three squares only three squares away
from queening it's not that far but yeah
thanks again exercise sparks probably
the first subscriber of today and I
don't think I had any yesterday so
thanks again please King f2 I was
expecting key me too
Oh bikini - Bishop g2 uh-huh so this
King is maybe stuck okay let's improve
miking man I have to like somehow
program Auto mod to allow the the name
yasser it's like it seems like every
stream someone mentions yasser and
although mod blocks it I'm sorry for
that yeah pushing baby
for anyone who hasn't heard the yasser
sarah one song on Spotify highly
recommend checking it out
I'm sure someone can provide a link in
the chat now everyone's saying yasser
and getting blocked by hollow mud I
don't have time for this
Bishop d1 okay keep moving the King like
in the practical situation with
increments black wants to play quickly
gain time and then save time for later
to actually think I think this yeah
it's allowed for some people but not
others it's weird so now he wants to
trade bishops really so if I take the
bishop he takes with King and then it's
all about the Queen side can I March at
least the C pawn
I also have about five here that doesn't
really make any sense yeah I think I can
just take take let's just calculate I
could probably calculate until the ends
King g7 Guinea to King c6 oh let's say
he just waits like Kingdom one here here
it should be for the problem is he might
just leave his King on c2 and play
Bishop g3 that could be really annoying
and how does black make progress I have
to somehow target III
that could be really annoying actually
oh maybe I can't trade bishops King goes
to see to that five doesn't really do
too much actually f5 does a lot f5 makes
a pass pawn
whoa okay take take I got my king to be
five he gets the scream - see - and then
I play something like f5 ideas at four
and then if I'd make two passed pawns it
should usually be winning it would give
him a pass H pawn but d4 is also weak
that's gotta be good
let's take seven yeah I forgot about
this f5 idea what would Jesus do okay
I'm gonna stop looking at the chat a
moment this is still a little unclear
he plays h4 which I sort of forgot about
can I take in place III Keaney - maybe
it doesn't work h4 is a good move
see three immediately also probably
doesn't work because just kini - wait
wait wait
see three no he could take on g5 see to
Bishop T - no no no so if I play c3 you
would probably take and I take H pawns
probably too weak okay this is gonna be
weird but I'm gonna take and play King
e7 I just don't like that so many pawns
are getting traded g7 g5 I have to play
F v g6 check whoa
no that should be okay if all my pawns
are light squares coz for in some
situations I think I have a feeling it's
it's winning but I'm not entirely sure
there's usually like these Satan colored
Bishop endings if one side of a pawn
it's enough for a win but he has like he
has this efore move and then the more
clones they get that get traded the
closer he is to a draw but now the issue
for him I have this idea of bringing the
king also can i play c3 here c3 king -
still doesn't work
wait then I take whoa Z for a mistake C
3 C 3 you might play no bishop take f6
take take no that doesn't work I just
want to play C 3 well if he plays me
five C 2
there should take us six king f7 Bishop
g5 and then Bishop e3 that wins and if
he plays well he could play King III but
then I take on before King f7 is a
simple move here but I'm gonna I'm gonna
play C 3 I don't see anything wrong with
it if he plays g5 g if I shouldn't work
running low on time too but the whole
point is that his King is currently
helping defend the e pawn but his King
also is now tasked with trying to stop
the C pawn that move I forgot about or
that move I just unconsciously rejected
cos C 2 and Bishop e3 this is winning
now maybe there is a better try
therefore White's
okay that ended abruptly let's go to the
analysis board I will say that this
tournament I'm not trying to win I'm
just trying to have decent quality and
instructive games let's start with the
opening because I'm actually really
curious about this Quincy to move third
most popular move black score as well
but what did you hear I mean black would
like to play Bishop f5 the problem is
Dee takes e5 and I'm not entirely sure
if this is actually working for black I
think white is happy here infinite flash
chess pointing out I am NOT trying to
him I might win anyway but we'll see
Oh bird 25 yeah good game bird real
quick stock fish
yeah White's just better so I played g6
which is the most common move played by
some good players 92 Bishop g7 Oh Bishop
g7 I should just keep the attention just
off this degree at Bishop g7 I kind of
forgot that if I play Bishop g7 I'm
leaving white in a situation where it's
not easy to like play a reasonable move
like he would like to develop the Bishop
to d3 but then I can play c4 and Bishop
f5 and if he develops a Bishop to e2
it's a bit more passive good morning mo
- man double-oh-seven so yeah I should
have probably just waited to play fish
about five um I am curious about this
line though because take
II take and then Bishop f5 for some
reason I thought sock fish was saying
that's bad for black oh no it was
looking I take I take T for wait what
be fine I take c6o so the game I was
thinking of that I had a few days ago I
had this position I didn't even consider
t5 but if I just like crushing because I
take the bishop and this might still
attacked any trees attacked okay that's
cool hello I am the real MC nice excuse
me let's just see what happened and like
later on because it was a little bit
uncomfortable like h6 was kind of slow
but I mean I think it was still probably
easier to play for a black because this
is a very clear idea
oh and why are you made some
inaccuracies
whoa sock fish being so so strong and so
computer like I don't think anyone would
consider it B take c3 because you're so
inclined to take the knight and what if
B take Bishop take huh so it would be
similar to what happened in the game
let's just jump to the end game
oh and computer already has analyzed
this yeah it was probably winning for
black the whole time there's a funny
line I was calculating here where if
like this g5f v g6 check King f8 Bishop
f6 it looks like White's getting some
counter play the problem is that all
these pawns on the light squares cannot
be attacked and I would just play King
g8 and then the C pawn is super
dangerous um so if Keaney - I could
probably somehow when the the g6 fun big
fish at f8 Bishop g7 and then somehow
get my team to g7 like this this maybe
even like Bishop h8 it's weird but
though I'm threatening King g7 can take
g6 so some ideas play after sin 3 C 3 is
just winning right because King me 3 I
can take yeah f5 could come at some
point okay good game very 25 I'm gonna
move on oh how many blunders do i me for
inaccuracy is one mistake aha
so I must be take C 3 Bishop take before
was bad what all these like stock fish
computer moves best move with g5 really
so you take me for
oh come on g5 and Bishop take before or
like very very similar okay
maybe the computer didn't spend enough
time cutting at is that what saying
Bishop take before sometimes you can't
always trust stockfish with these uh
like game summaries yeah you actually
have to look at like the specific lose a
bit closer I'm gonna move on play
another game hade I'm in the top 400 and
do I wanna do its way to London I
apologize for the people who might be
bored by the London but this openings
really exciting for me maybe okay this
guy's here so bismuth 4 so we're two for
two on the London's for today he plays
g6 so this will not be a typical London
this is gonna be what's known as a berry
attack where he's attempting to play
King's Indian but it's not quite King's
Indian because I haven't played c4 and
it's actually more of a perk
now it's kind of a weird perk because my
bishops committed to at four but it's
it's just a different type of opening an
idea for whites is to Castle queenside
and in many cases go for like the early
Bishop h6 like f3 kind of treat it like
some sort of dragging us off
the fukes yeah you misspelled perk it's
spelled like that actually in Russia or
in most countries they pronounce it
Pierce like the C is not pronounced like
okay so he plays Knight d7 which looks
like he wants to play this e5 move so
just preventing me five very
multi-purpose control the center and
yeah just prophylaxis I get blocks main
idea is to play e5 it's actually not
that easy to get in with with white
having three three attackers on e5
square and there is a funny trap at some
point which I'll have to remember I'm
trying to remember this position because
I remember if we if I can miss sunlight
to f3 I'm pretty sure it means that
White Castle kingside it's only a flight
plays pawn f3 should White Castle
queenside but it's been a while since
I've looked at the prep actually it's
been uh what am I trying to say I
actually haven't done too much cracked
in this line maybe I looked it like one
or two lines from this position I'm
gonna play Bishop c4 because it's just a
normal developing move and it sets up
like a kind of dirty trap which maybe
he'll walk into I'm not gonna say
anything because he might be watching
would be nice to know if he had the
stream you to pick my last opponent but
I guess I won't know that X I sparks is
asking when you trade dark-squared
bishop oh so when do I play Bishop h6
not right now
I want a complete development and then
decide like this idea with Bishop h6
it's it's going to be present in the
position for a while now in other lines
if I Castle queenside Bishop h6 usually
comes pretty quickly because it would be
a much sharper position but
this position might actually be a lot
more positional where it's just about
trying to get a central bind and
restricting black and if that's the case
I probably don't want to trade pieces c6
looks like a useful move it has house a
couple ideas you might want to play p4
or b5 even b5 before you might also want
to play some probably not d5 right away
but maybe like Knight a key for 1984 25
question is do I want to do anything to
stop him or should I just castle my
castle he plays b5 I should note that if
he ever ticks on e4
I'll take with Knights and he plays d5 I
have Bishop d3 I think that's very
reasonable for whites
so I Castle he plays b5 I play Bishop b3
he plays before and whites losing a
partner so I Castle he plays b5 I play
Bishop d3 I want my bishop on the good
diagonal so a5 looks very tempting or uh
we can't talk today
a4
stopping b5 prophylaxis let's play a
four gives a bishop some breathing room
now I guess I'll go ahead and say what
the trap was because I don't think it's
ever gonna work anymore but if we go
back to moose or one move if you really
wanted to play e5 he could have maybe
tried rookie Yeates but rook e8 would
have been a serious blunder with this as
it runs into very thematic they should
take a 17 take f7 by g5
King would go back and then like u6
traps the Queen so funny opening trap I
don't think I've ever had that in like a
real game this Bishop taking seven it's
bound to happen eventually so he's
thinking so far I've played to somewhat
important prophylactic moves Knight f3
stopping a five and a four stopping d5
and usually when you have more space
that's one of the main strategies you
just want to restrict your opponent you
don't necessarily want to like attack
and kill them if you just restrict them
it can it can be more effective it can
also provoke lunders infinite flash just
pointing out d5 would probably hang upon
unless it doesn't hang up on d5 take
like b6 it's interesting maybe d5 works
do five take maybe six it should be
three I think most of the middle game's
White's gonna be slightly better lucky
even if he got some central break-in
we'll get some position where I'll have
a pawn on d4 like this line
I'll take I assume this is okay maybe I
moved too quickly there maybe I should
have considered I should take a seven I
was just pretty set on d5 and then
Bishop d3 I will think here I should
consider options so I'm imagining some
position like Bishop d3 he takes I take
906 bishop goes back to d3 and like the
pawn on d4 it gives white slightly more
space so it's just a mental game like
stuff more interesting stuff will happen
from there I know there's any other move
to consider I mean Bishop take d5 just
gives away the bishop pair
Knight f6 is dumb
yeah what else to consider yeah let's
just play Bishop d3
you should have probably visits
that's how you win the tournaments so
monkey Dee bill giving some very
insightful advice my goal I said this
earlier but my goal is not to win the
tournament I don't think I'll even be
able to finish like half of this
tournament it's four and a half hours
I'm just trying to play some like decent
quality games and get my skin or my my
classical rating slightly higher if I
play a really low rate of player maybe
I'll buzzer just so I can try and play
higher rated players later okay push it
back to d3 so it's the middlegame
position
I'll Castle very shortly I was about to
make an observation that his bishop
didn't have anywhere great to go now I'm
realizing Bishop g4 I want to play 95
but I can't play 95 because Queen take
t4 I think so this could already be some
issue for whites and all their move I
want to play this e3 but then he can
take my clan structure is kind of bad so
what do I do here at Bishop e2 the
should be 2 looks really passive but it
might be the best move
looks really passive is 94 Queen III I
should have probably calculated this
from the time I took on e4 or even when
I played a four seed the follow-up for
black play Bishop e2 he has a 95 gives 9
h5 I think I survive
I'm trying to figure out like if I play
c3 he takes I take is the bishop pair
worth having the double pawns I don't
think I like that so I'm wondering can I
stack the D pawn in some mines 995 queen
takes e4 Knight takes e4
mighty chief or the only reason why I'm
reluctant to play Bishop e2 is because
it looks ugly but it might just be okay
if I can castle and play c3 it will be
very ok I'm gonna do it I don't see
anything wrong with it
I mean it's slightly embarrassing the
number of times I've moved my bishop
like starting I moved 10 I moved it once
no I've moved it I moved it to c4 as
well so starting to move 7 that's once
twice three times four times I've moved
the same piece five times in the last 13
moves
so maybe not following the best opening
principles but I'm just trying to like
get some slight edge like here there's
an argument that like there's already
some slight edge I have a pawn on d4
slightly more space the objective with
Bishop e2 is if I play h3e takes I take
I have the bishop pair which is another
side edge so I'm essentially pointing
the question to see whether he can
punish me for playing too slowly here 95
so I saw this I just assumed Bishop to
g3
and I could allow him to take my could
castle but I don't want to give black
the bishop air
oh also he's threatening to take take on
a three and then take on g4 so if I play
c3 he takes I take my bishop g3 looks
fine so G 3 c3 will come very soon
I can move I'll move like Queen b6 I can
play c3 try and dampen the power of this
Bishop how's that c4 c4 c5
let's see for positioning it looks
weakening because like then d4 will be
harder to defend I mean the whole idea
is I like make the night awkward like
night before but then probably a 5 and I
win material so see 494 a 5 that looks
good so c4 when light doesn't have too
many more options if 97 I have a 5 so is
c4 forcing on us 6 because if it is June
I have 6 might be a fine option because
he's threatening 94 but then I have time
to Castle 9423
you
let's look at throwing some 85 move it's
a question do I want to be aggressive
we're gonna be solid and I think the the
way I arrived at the conclusion is to
just calculate this whole scenario of a
c4 c4 906 so I'm realizing if he was up
to d8 the Queen could get stuck with a 5
it feels weird to attack him with my
king still in the center but let's do it
am I missing any like Bishop take a 3
intermezzo
we should take a 3 take a 3 I don't
think so okay I'm doing it it feels
wrong but it might be right it should be
right that's the thing if you don't see
anything wrong with the move you play it
very something wrong you learn from it
but I'm pretty sure my left six is
forced
the question is do I wanna play a 5 or C
5 or the way or castle right away so I
don't play a 5 right away he could play
a 5 some positional some positional
weakness on b4
I am making an effort not to look at the
chat but just because there's so many
comments to keep up with and I'm trying
to focus on the game I don't want to
offer a draw how did that happen there
okay
so he plays -6 I'm also not looking in
the chat because people might be
suggesting moves I don't want to get any
bias think a 5 might be the best
approach so if I play a 5 you place
Queen b3 I played rook a 3 when the
Queen's trapped meanwhile the only move
is Queen g8 which is a very good sign
I mean there's still ideas for him to
play like 94 let's say Queen dat would
be threatening 94 get the bishop hair
than this Bishop is really annoying so
I'm thinking Queen g8 I play Queen III
just restricting him Queen da Queen III
what does black do there's been a lot of
prophylaxis this game a lot of just
preventive nice trying to make sure that
thought can't get what he wants
oh no drawers before move 30 really
interesting
so I could play Queen III I'm also
looking at h3 but h3 might just run into
94 it was also the exuberance Queen f4
that looks too exuberant play Queen e3
still not castled it's move 17 the
problem for black like he didn't want
his light to go back to f6 and even when
his queen to go back to d8 the queen is
blocking the rooks from coming in and
the Knights locking the Bishop from
coming in so I have played some weird
moves but I've made it so black's pieces
can't be as protective 9 h5 is a move
that I completely missed it might be a
good move because he's he wants the
bishop here and he wants to he's
actually threatening to win a pawn I
think with like taking everything and
then eventually winning d4 so the first
move that comes to mind is just Bishop
e5 there should be 5 I think you can
take me 5 because I take with pawn this
might stuck he plays a 6f 6 is gonna be
annoying for both of us my bishop gets
stucked at his Bishop gets stuck
so there's an e5 f6 Bishop g3 and he
could play f5 I move back to e5 it's
such a weird line but I think it's okay
there's also the sliding Bishop e5 f6
Bishop g3 you could take take on g3 HK
g3 and then play out five I have 95 in
the end let's do it yeah I'm not sure if
this guy will follow the time feingold
rule of never fly off six cuz f6 is a
reasonable move but I don't know maybe
he'll play something else
chess para mental is asking how about
Bishop h4 I didn't even consider dish of
h4 probably because actually why cuz
Bach could take and then take on g4 I
needed to defend the thon
I thought this was gonna be relaxing but
I'm actually using a lot of energy like
these positions I'm getting into they're
requiring a lot of lot of efforts let's
check this guy's ratings from Chile
let's play the decent amount of
classical okay fair enough
yeah maybe somewhat of a critical moment
for black cuz whatever choice he makes
it's going to be committal like f6 he
plays f6 pawns can't move backwards and
he's either forever locking in his
bishop or just like weakening the Kings
side if he does go for the eventual f5
if he doesn't play f6 I guess he could
just ignore everything that I'm doing I
should probably stop talking you might
be listening to me and just find some
ideas so I'm gonna be right back I'm
gonna get some juice I'll see what he
does
okay he's still thinking it's good sign
oh no ki kala finally caught a stream
yeah I usually don't stream it this time
I usually stream like late at night at
least about a central time but I've been
making an effort to actually put
together a schedule for streaming okay
he plays out 653 so I think f5 you know
originally I thought I find this a
critical line with the threat of that 4
but f5 Bishop e5
yeah I've been moving the bishops a lot
in this game well that's why we want to
go back and like look at the being
because I have a feeling I probably miss
played it somewhere but I'm actually not
sure if I've been worse yet so he's
taking so this is one of the lines I was
looking at if he plays f5 I can play 95
and the night will be very very strong
on e5 only issue with that if he takes
on e 2 I might have to take the king to
keep the d4 pawn defended
there is a rule in chess so like if
you're if the H file opens and you
haven't castled and it's usually okay to
just not castle and put the King on f1
because this rook will exert pressure in
the position so even if my king like has
to capture on e2 if I eventually just
put it on f1 it should be relatively
safe
he plays Queen d7 so keeping the tension
very non-committal move I'm now I'm
tempted to Castle just get the rook to
the center it would break the rule but
okay if I Castle he plays that five I
play 95 I hit the Queen so there's no
time to take on you too
I mean if I Castle a DA that's probably
likely and then work a deal on looks
okay
I'm not sure what else to look at here I
think I just want to Castle and put the
roots in the center do you want anyone
and then the this is a problem situation
for him his bishops box by the Athlon if
he ever plays that five then there's 95
so yeah I'm just gonna try and reinforce
the center I guess there is one thing
that I maybe figure out about but if it
happens it'll be interesting or he could
take on that three remove the night and
then play f5 and then some obstacle our
Bishop positioned which might be Josh
but because Queens are on the board it
could also be very sharp where we
probably both want to attack on the
Kings side yeah whatever happens it's
gonna be interesting I guess I could
calculate Bishop take out three fish if
they got three five okay that didn't
happen so you really want to play e5
that looks wrong he is he's also over
defending the Imam
it seems a bit strange debating which
rook to move to d1 I love it matters too
much
we were FD 1 my a Brooke is doing
something there might be some positional
idea here
- it looks anti positional but to play
c5
it does give him the d5 square but if I
can get in a 6 and just destroy the
queenside structure it could be worth it
also opens up my bishop to go to c4 and
he doesn't have any Knights like if you
got a knight to stick on d5 mate maybe
it would be different but and c5 could
be interesting and of course there's
also d5 a couple couple pawn breaks to
look at
I guess c5 is in the pawn break but c5
would prepare the break with a 6
I also have to like just keep an eye on
tactics like of course 95 doesn't quite
work right away but maybe in the future
probably not right now
my g5 could be a move right this is why
tactics are important Knight g5 he takes
and I'm I'm Aiden by force at Knight g5
actually a good move it was 95 his
bishop could just drop back but I have
96 we have some obstacle our Bishop
ending I think I want to start with c5
and just like keep an eye g5 idea in my
back pocket and just open up some more
ideas let's do that somewhat intuitive
decision but I feel like if he has to be
concerned about Knight g5 now he else
also has to be concerned about Bishop c4
Czech Queen b3 check a6 so just trying
to create more resources
and I don't know if it's the best
objective decision but from the
practical standpoint I'm just I'm just
trying to provoke some blunder from
black or some kind of mistake okay rook
to e8 so now the issue is if I play
Knight g5 there's situations where d4
could hang for example when I g5 he
takes I take maybe it's I don't want to
open up his bishop though this bishop
deserves to be stuck so a6 looks nice
but a6 b5 maybe I play Queen b3 and then
a six
this choice is here it's also Bishop c4
there's this funny idea Bishop c4 or
King h8 Bishop e6 not too much time to
decide I was looking at a 6 earlier than
B 5 and if I want to take I'd have 2 on
Posada takes with Queen I don't know if
I'm getting anywhere there well there's
also some idea like Bishop c4 King h8
Bishop f7 go after the e7 pawn so many
ideas ok what to do if I go for this
Bishop e6 idea we trade bishops he puts
the work on d5 doesn't look that great
well Queen b3 King h8 in 96 just hard to
judge and I come back to my g5 of course
the first move I was looking at is now
I'm realizing if he takes on g5 if I
take on g4 his g5 ponds week this Kings
opening up I might lose d4 though you
move to like just keep all the pressure
okay I just have to make a move I'm
gonna go from that g5 I think it's okay
worst comes to worst we'll get some
office of Claudia Bishop ending which
will probably be a draw it looks
interesting it's gonna be very sharp
because this King will be more open this
pawn structure will be if he I was very
reluctant to play this move because it
helps him open up the darks for a bishop
if he wants to take the Knights but it
is a trade off I'm pretty sure he'll
take g5 I'll actually be pretty
surprised if he does something else I
would be very grateful if you take sunny
to
but one of the perks with having the
structure if we trade if he takes on g5
I take on g4 rook d5 usually will run to
bishop t6 so he can't really set up a
blockade and that might allow some
future d5 break if I can trade off the D
pawn then he'll be left with some
weaknesses on the Kings side so this is
interesting I'm not sure what he could
be thinking about here I mean maybe he's
not watching the stream and just really
surprised by Knight g5 are there any
other moves like Bishop Bishop h6 a move
so it could be doesn't look right though
Bishop h6 Queen b3 and then bad stuff
happens to black
this is a sort of situation I can't
really sit back and relax even though I
want to because low on time
I haven't really calculated too far
after after what happens in this line by
juicy ideas okay I didn't see any five
coming um I take on g5 or do I play I
don't want to play d5 first u5 is
probably a good move because t5 doesn't
work right away I could take
let me just trade everything I can also
play Queen b3 and then d5 Queen b3 is
Queen f7
take-take-take
good move this rookie one work rookie
one rookie one could be a candidate move
actually I don't know if it's any good
it's hard to evaluate like all the
possibilities I have to move low on time
[Music]
what to do take I don't play rookie one
we might get in some situation where
they'll have Queen and pawn against the
two rooks but at least we'll be
interesting and dynamic like if he takes
on d4 then we get in that situation I'm
thinking it should be fine for white
because White's pieces can coordinate
the only issue is time like can i play
accurately with less than two minutes if
he doesn't take on d4 I'm probably ready
to take on e5
and play some Queen b3 move and then
maybe go for a six I don't think there's
any rush to capture the g5 fun so yeah
very interesting position
plays efore which I kind of disregarded
but looks like an okay move what to do
he wants to take on D for now I could
take on g5 it should take like Rock a
four I just have to move quicker 41 okay
I'm gonna play Brooke do you wanna I
defend the D pawn I'm allowing him to
take on e5 and then things are gonna get
messy things could get really messy in
this position - look on the bright side
is G pawns weak his be pawns kind of
backwards this econ is actually a
long-term weakness because it's just
fixed on the light square at some point
I should be able to win it but my
bishops a little bit misplaced on g4 I'd
like my bishop test somehow get to this
diagonal maybe Bishop e2 ideas there
should be - Bishop c4 for my King safer
than his King
okay he takes 185 I'm like win the b7
pawn might be losing d4 but I win ce6
things could get raided pretty quickly
rook never gave one I'll probably just
take on b7 right away there is some
concern about f2 but yeah there's no
time to be concerned I'm calculating an
interesting line if he takes with the
bishop oh I can't take as he takes on
Iman that's annoying
yeah he takes with bishop okay I played
before
wait a minute b4 will probably play
Queen a 2 I take on d4 he takes and then
Queen f7
oh no Queen f7 is awesomeness the Queen
takes c6 second exchange or just Queen
wait Queen takes c6 right away there's
no tactics right III my king can always
run I Rexford defended okay simple move
there might be some threat of actually I
don't want to say any threats he could
very well be watching yeah both Kings
can be under targets pretty quickly his
Kings safe because he's on the dark
square I can't really attack along with
the agonal my king
being on the dark square is somewhat
vulnerable yeah rook f8 I was expecting
I think this is an okay move Bishop take
f2 or take F to take take his Queen e1
and things ooh
it's not good actually take take take
take
I played before before there there oh my
gosh running one time I don't think he
needs to I'm just trying to like
get my king to a safe place and then
maybe when the e4 pawn
I've 16 seconds left this is supposed to
be slow chess well there's some there's
a myriad of traps in this position I
still don't know what's going on traps
for both sides I guess before it's gonna
fall after he was gonna fall both Kings
are under attack there is a ten-second
increment which is good c5 is gonna fall
yeah things are everything's hanging all
my pawns are hanging at least he's
thinking a king safety first
plays III let's take understanding III
so you could have just won the pawn you
also play Bishop e5 maybe
it seems slow okay he takes their uh we
could trade down to it very Josh I mean
I don't want to trade down but I'll do
it maybe e4 let's do this this Bishop f3
solid move oh then he winds up on wait a
mite up upon here I can't count
no that's equal pawn structure is really
bad for white three pawns bishop I feel
it was just a bad move I should be able
to hold this for a draw but even like
officer Clark Bishop things with rooks
can be a bit complex because the bishops
and rooks can coordinates and then try
and target squares in the pawns
territory sometimes all three results
are possible and also with the time
situation laundries can happen okay
yeah I have to take with rook and give
away that pawn right I take there
actually I take with bishop holding on
to material
and then I'll play b3 it looks really
passive but at least the pawns will be
defended I want to play e4 next box
probably slightly better okay let's see
what happens
I mean White's the only player with the
past pawn and my works behind this so
that's something but my bishop on do you
want is such a bad piece we're gonna
play E for the bishop just wants to go
to like d5 then it's happy defending the
pawns on a more active square I just
keep pushing the pawn now I'm gonna play
Bishop to g4
try and do some maneuvering wait I do
have to be careful here though there's
ideas for black there's ideas for white
- yeah that's good move I just play e5
maybe Bishop f3
yeah Bishop f3 I can lose that pond and
start pushing the econ so white style
upon but this e pawn is slightly
dangerous
both sides a long time might have to go
for some like swindle chief or really
also play Bishop f2 okay I can afford to
lose that I'm like okay one no okay one
where is my Brooklyn ago okay okay whoa
wait did I just plunger everything I
think I've wondered everything I was
probably a really bad move was my king
stuck oh please [ __ ] he takes with rook
really
Bishop f3 you should take with Bishop
there and just take on you five there's
now his bishop and rook are weird down
upon but this one still somewhat strong
if I really want to never mind
okay what to do here wait a minute I
have to do that mmm it's still awkward
yeah to do this
let's attack the bishop I think he had
chances to win earlier but now I know
it's still weird
I haven't pawn on e6 he's trying to trap
my bishop if he goes for g4 it should
just be a draw yeah we'll trade
everything what's the best way to take
take take yeah this king will be cut off
oh he does that's my bishop still
trapped I'm gonna cut off his king
and then take here okay
I'm not winning this but it should be a
very easy job plays a five can i for Kim
let's for Kim you got forked it's still
a dry take bring the rip to like a two
or maybe even bring my kingdom
kingi for a for wreckage one that's just
a draw just a matter of technique or
just a matter of not letting his punk
removed
offer draw flavor okay - okay - I defend
my pawn and now I just want to win his
pawn so he declined the draw but I'm
gonna win this one first
okay it was a draw that would be really
funny if he Mouse lips like King f2 or
King eh - am i afraid she for one win
let's go to the houses board interesting
game it's disappointing not to win that
my my perfect record in classical chess
is now dead after only two games but
still undefeated okay so this opening
you played 97 preparing me five i play
nine of three this is all normal
I'm gonna leave on stockfish because I
know it comes up with some interesting
ideas here uh but it looks like yeah
maybe I should have just been consistent
with my plans just Castle queenside for
some reason I thought it was okay to
Castle kingside
but this looks okay so my opponent just
messaged me saying he missed Knight g5
which maybe wasn't that impressive
um yeah overall it looks like it was a
clean game computer analysis oh it's
still working
okay so yeah maybe this line it's like
it's actually just a dragon Sicilian but
from a very strange move order and this
would be very preferable for lights but
I played Bishop c4 which probably is
just not a good move I play Bishop c4
because I thought I had studied it
before
Oh c5 here also possible you played c6
mmm yeah that's already comfortable for
black b5 I didn't consider is mine h5 6
this looks really interesting maybe a
bit too extravagant but I don't know if
I believe in this like white gave up the
bishop here like slot casts fold it's
interesting though Queen h4 get some
positional game okay let's see what
happens
cuz I played a4 and yeah he played well
tonight take me for and d5 we went for
this line which I forgot I forgot he
could play Bishop g4 in the very end
here's otherwise white should be better
if I can like just somehow play h3 or
play c3 sooner the Bishop g4 very strong
move and then it was a game of cat and
mouse I kept defending I think c4 was
nice
yeah I was feeling pretty good here
queen III apparently a mistake
there should be five I didn't consider
yeah I I do apologize the chat is just
so hard to keep up with I do see the
viewer count like the chat is never this
active but I'm just gonna go forward
analyze this game and then then I'll
look at the comments so let's go forward
to some critical moment as I was feeling
I was still feeling good here oh so this
is where I wanted to play Knight g5 but
I played c5 cuz I thought it was a
better practical decision but Knight g5
right away if he takes I guess it's
different that's a lot different if he
plays a5 I probably have 95 this would
have been good okay fair enough
I think after E 5 I'm good so yeah my
phone is actually setting me some
messages if I was definitely good move
but it's still very complex use obstacle
our Bishop positions can be very
deceiving I'm just wondering was there
any blunders
were there any blunders that happened in
this position because I had so little
time th2 was just instinctive but maybe
the right decision yeah I just kind of
fizzled out
but yeah later I just completely
butchered the defense cuz yeah he
brought his rook and he's already
threatening Bishop f2 in this position
and after a bishop f3 I lose a pawn g4
was very strong and yeah in this
position he should just take what is
going on someone else making moves no
one else should have control
maybe stockfish is doing analysis no no
just Bishop take g3 and then King g1
take it tax my rook and I have no time
there's two reasons why I can't take a
seven they're actually just one reason
as a bishop t4 or rook e1 and then
Bishop d4 so black would just be up to
pawns here and like a strong player with
should convert this pretty easily he's
black okay um I think what I'll do I'll
play one more game I'll try and at least
have a another win near my goats and I
think I still gained rating points oops
I didn't want to go there what am i
doing I'm one thing I clicked the wrong
thing
uh oh man
I'm struggling with this treatment I'm
still in the top 500 hello there's
almost 1500 players in this it's a lot
of players like a refresh okay I chose
I'm streaming that's good
people are discussing cheaters yeah oh
yeah I definitely was not playing a
cheater it was very human play but okay
this guy's busy working against me
we'll make this a 10 minute game I guess
I'll play it before this game will be a
bit more aggressive let's play my
favorite opening what's his rating and
other chess okay so it shouldn't be a
scary opponent he plays a 6 I'm gonna
stick with the Grand Prix setup going
for 903 and then usually the eventual
Bishop to b5 and if he lets me take on
c6 it should be yeah it should be very
pleasant for for whites d3 it's a
problem in a lot of these positions this
Bishop is just kind of stuck and move
like d5 I usually can just ignore but
what's the best way to ignore it
white doesn't want to play e5 maybe
Queen e1 or Queen e2 probably Queen e2
there is some positional trap which I'm
not going to say actually the very first
time I played this sort of opening I
played it from the backside and I fell
into the positional trap he didn't fall
into vision basics looks very reasonable
the trap is if black plays t4 it's just
really really bad for huh for black the
pawns get fixed but I'm gonna try and
like get some clamp I'm gonna play b3
first and there's some idea of playing
like nine a four and then c4 if the pawn
can somehow get to see four it's just
incredible for whites it's about making
that happen
94 immediately might not be the right
decision because you can take on e4 yeah
definitely not the right decision
okay I'm gonna play slowly huge one a
typical Sicilian of ooh he moves his
mind away relieving pressure on me for
let's play nine a four looks like he
wants to play Bishop f6 which just walks
in to be five so nice g7 was very
strange matter fate also very strange
I'm gonna play a c4 when for anyone who
plays this opening is white like this is
a dream especially with this warden
structure against the CC pawns if you
can place before it just completely
shuts down the whole Queen side but he's
taking though not too much time night g6
I'm just gonna be solid like g3 there's
no rush here for whites
there's bishops gonna be stuck hopefully
the whole game f5
can I take and then play a queen e6
check and then win the pawn
I mean e5 is also very tempting I'm
gonna play d5 because I have a pretty
good understanding of what's going on in
this position where the c5 funds just so
long-term targets and probably what the
goal is probably something like Bishop
e3 provoke him to play d4 and then go
back to a3
and now it's a very close position where
his bishops are just awful and I'm gonna
start exerting pressure on this pawn
it's not the easiest pond to defend even
though it is defended once I should a3
calmness reminds me of some names oh
it's like a reverse names oh I playing
against these double plants Oh in Queen
a5 I can probably just play Queen d2 and
I think yeah white wins upon by force we
either trade Queens and then I win the
pond or he retreats when when the phone
right away I just glanced at the chats
hello chess gee how's it going I
apologize to all the other people who
probably said hi I didn't respond to
hello everyone uh he's sacking the
exchange I probably want to take it now
if I don't take them he can take here so
what material feels pretty good now the
one issue here is that if he plays he 5
in Bishop d7 there's some compensation
because the bishop is goes from what was
his worst piece probably his best piece
question is can I prevent that can i
play
c5 but then Bishop takes e5 that might
be worth it c5 Bishop takes e5 we open
the C file
more importantly we trade pieces I'm
gonna do it somewhat intuitive decision
maybe not the best decision
realizing d3 could be weak but I just
wanted to trade off my nights and now c6
like the C pawn should be weak for a
long time Derek c1 I would like to take
he takes on d3
maybe that's not just not good I take on
before he takes on d3 there's some
pressure
okay so d3 is weak what to do could just
play king g1 just be patient if you play
c5 it's a move then Queen c2 my nice
solid I'm gonna 3 wait is there a simple
line here if I take on b4 he takes on d3
I take on d4 we turn on my fun choices
choices okay I'm gonna start with king g
1c five possible and then c5 should be
weak for a while hopefully okay he plays
c5 this should be sevens coming play
rook see - wait I have to think except I
can't think cuz I desert there's a lot
much time I hope I'm not butchering
another another position
um a3 is a break I'm gonna start with
Quincy - he's trying I tried to get him
to think my slop to exchange it should
be should be okay good move yeah well
not just play a three a three take them
and work a one thing is when you're up
the exchange it's not a huge advantage
if there aren't any open files so the
goal for white is to open at least one
file which is what I'm trying to do with
a three and then if he takes I'll play
rook a1 and life should be a little bit
better I would hope if he doesn't take
I'll take on before oh he's allowing me
to take on before and then take on c8
and that would be interesting take take
take take he wins the b-pawn I wouldn't
deep on he wins the deep on
I'm so tempted oh we beserk so there's
no increment well I have to move faster
then let's do it
it looks like a fun line if I lose I'll
learn hopefully but no this should just
be better for whites because this is a
very active rook I just want to double
up somewhere like rook c1 first weight
rook c1 hangs a knight what am i doing
so 95 mm Erick see why it should be good
IG 5 maybe Rick a one work a one hit a
pawn this might be my last game I was
playing three classical games in a row
even though this is this was a 10 minute
game it's tiring so if I play okay one
he plays a five so I should play what
should I play
you know Wow
okay I'm gonna play Brooksie for just
offend cuz I didn't want to lose b3 and
there will still be opportunities for
rook c7 hopefully when the time is right
my chief I probably wasn't the best
option okay let's do this
discouraging any a for ideas keeping his
Queen tied down to the eighth on h6 is
really annoying but I have to deal with
it my knight doesn't want to be on h3 it
wants to be on f3 I guess he does have
Queen f3 here but then light f2 ok let's
play king f2 ideas of this in this own
xe5 I forgot about let's throw in a
check I better not lose this with such a
good position earlier on it's still
probably better for white but it's
getting tricky b1 than a 4 out
I hurts okay 90 my cheat one I guess the
goal is to get both rooks to the seventh
and get some counter play I have to
manage my time too
he wins d3 this is not looking good I
think I can still hold on my rooks are
powerful this is a type of position all
three results are possible probably not
the most high-quality games today but
still some entertaining games if I had
to choose I would still prefer white
because white has at least a draw should
have at least two draw just a matter can
the rooks be powerful enough to win I
don't think there's perpetual my King
can run
I mean he wants to Queen but it takes it
takes at least three moves to Queen I'm
already threatening some rook f7 Jack
it's a critical moment for him what
every move he plays he's committing to
something it's easier to play for white
because all I want to do is like rook f7
and start checking him and then look for
mating ideas a my knight even though
it's inactive it's doing enough
preventing any sort of Perpetual Queen
e2 if you just hang me than one you just
fling made him one well that was that
was actually sort of unfortunate that
you didn't get to see what was going on
there I mean I was expecting some like I
don't know t3 move question is is white
winning stockfish I didn't want running
I did see the engine was evaluating so I
got everything I wanted from the opening
rook before was a good move good
practical move probably the best moves
right one of the best moves and then I
completely mishandled this position c5
robbing Holly good move
well I didn't even consider a3 a3 so
simple though yeah it goes just show my
form let's go to the end because things
got messy I went for this song which
probably wasn't necessary
yeah okay Brooke a1 and safer option
yeah I was excited to play like rook F
c1 rook c7 that he defends and like
wings my pawns so I didn't want to take
the risk then stuff happened h6 was
really important
maybe I should play King f2 here at King
f2 just so yeah rotate one is really bad
because my knight cannot go to f3 in
this position if I play King f2 I'm just
preparing Knight f3 to wreck a one this
should just be better for whites
um yeah White has a clear edge yeah and
I realized it after I played it like he
knifed you anyway made things
interesting King f8 maybe Oh King f8
defends g7 okay so we got to this
position 85 checkmate yeah checkmate is
unavoidable when your opponent has made
it one so if he plays Queen wait what
does the computer sing if he plays Queen
d2 I would play King h3d oh maybe he
escapes with some like Queen d1 I start
checking this isn't easy for black I
mean I thought what might happen is
after it b3 here let's say here and then
take then here check here and then
something like this threatening some
stuff and then if here it's such a
tricky position like rook h7 f king g8
but the knight is doing enough to help
defend
I want to move well maybe you're a cure
and then threatening Murphy eight mates
I was picturing something like this
where he's just running out of defenses
so let's see like how how does a
computer draw because again people are
discussing whether my opponent was
getting assistance but no my opponent
made several yeah several like human
mistakes
I also made several human mistakes I
think there were a lot of blunders this
game yeah so it's not a high quality
game so yeah let's see how sock fish
draws is Queen d2 check teenage 300g
five rook f7 g5 so powerful so
resourceful to in many lines I can win
the G pawn like with tempo against the
king that's not an easy man to find
Queen d2 or even g5 right away
so my King runs out of runs out in
squares King H 3 g5 if take take wait
what's going on your rook rook h7
G for news for take H - wait what so
White's just about winning but the
computer is still saying it's strong
after Queen take h7 how is that even
possible
like supper rook d3 work h2o and I see
for King at six this is insane
whites so close to winning this Knights
just completely restricted though it's a
crazy line Wow okay yeah clearly no one
was using an edge in this game not this
good at chess uh it was okay at least it
was a somewhat instructive opening
anyone who plays this Grand Prix's out
of his white like this is a really
really well-known structure to destroy
black but yeah I think I'm gonna end the
stream there there were a lot of people
watching I'm sorry I didn't get a chance
to interact at the chat as much as usual
but hopefully people took away something
or at least we're somewhat entertained
I'll be back in the future I'm not
entirely sure when my next dream will be
probably on Saturday or Sunday so
sometime over the over the weekend and
wait who's Rebecca Harris because I saw
that name yesterday has it been revealed
maybe it has oh thanks for the cheer X
weighs 40 bits appreciate it
oh narrative ski uh-huh interesting what
is a good video on the Grand Prix online
wait are you off as a joke question
let me let me just go to a new tap here
I am Rosen I'll just do a little bit of
self-promotion you can go to my video
lectures and I'll share the link in the
chat but if you want to grab free video
you can watch that I think that's the
right video okay
I'm ending it see you guys bye oh thanks
but seven for the follow